what does it mean to be out here today
and i mean you got charles barkley
talking trash right next to you yeah no
it's great man i mean it's uh it's kind
of right before you know camp for a lot
of these football guys this kind of last
hurrah but everyone's primed up and
i mean yeah there's a lot of a lot of
sticks out here
yeah hey um you get tom cruise over a
billion dollars for the first time he
just needed to team up with you earlier
how does that feel yeah that's
definitely what my team has been you
know saying um
for these future negotiations but now
it's great i mean tom is
i just sent a message the other day for
his birthday for him to you know share
top gun with me and a lot of these
other young actors and to bring us into
that world it's just been such a such a
wild ride i can't it's and it's
[Music]
will it be a top gun sequel will we see
you again oh that i mean that would be
that would be great but that's all up to
to tc that's all up to tom
you hollering by the i yeah i've been
i've been uh having some conversations
with him about it but you know we'll see
all right will you intimidate some of
these guys if you say i got a shirtless
scene you know i've got a shirtless
scene i don't know about you charles
barkley but i got a shirtless thing yeah
i would i wouldn't um shirtless scene
would look a little different
these days we shot that a couple years
ago but yeah we'll see maybe i'll give a
little wiggle if i get a nice eagle or
something your grandma wants you to be
james bond will you do that she wants me
to be yeah i mean yeah perfect i think
that's it's a good
but it is kind of true you know i think
you can
we're actors yeah so maybe you can
mix it up a little bit hey um by the way
the offer will there be a second season
and what what can we expect to see i
don't know
as of now i'd say i would say no
yeah yeah i mean once they make the
godfather you know that's kind of that's
that's it oh thanks appreciate it